- Hi, everyone Sal ,
here from Khan Academy,
welcome to our "Homeroom Live Stream".
I'm out here in California
where the sky is looking very ominous
it looks like, yeah,
you can't it's bizarre
I've never quite seen this,
for those of y'all who don't know
there's these forest fires in East, well,
we've had a few near us
and now there's some in Eastern California
and you're in the Sierra Nevadas
and that I've been studying the weather
the smoke is going over us
at a very high altitude.
Apparently our air isn't that bad
because the Marine layer
is coming under it so we're
getting reasonably fresh air,
but it looks very ominous
when you look them in the sky,
you really can't see the sky, but anyway,
with that a little bit
of interesting context,
I encourage people to do a web search
for satellite images of California
fires it is mind blowing,
but really excited about
this conversation today
other than what's going on
in the meteorologist world,
we're gonna have a team
member, Dave Travis
to talk about all of the work we do here
at Khan Academy on SAT
and answer any questions
you might have on the SAT.
So start thinking of those,
put your questions in the
message boards on Facebook
and YouTube and we will try
to get to as many of those as possible
but before we jump into that conversation,
I will give my standard announcements,
a reminder to all of
y'all that Khan Academy
is a not-for-profit organization.
We can only exist through
philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please go to @www.Khanacademy.org/donate
Also wanna give a special shout out
to several organizations
that have helped Khan Academy
over the years, but especially
over the last few months,
as we were already running at a deficit
and you can imagine our
costs have only grown.
Now that COVID has hit
and our traffic is many
fold of what it normally is
and we're trying to accelerate
a whole bunch of programs,
so special thanks to Bank of
America, Google.org, AT&T,
fastly. and Novartis of stepping up
and helping us fill some of that gap
but we still need more help.
So once again, if you're
in a position to do so,
please think about donating.
So with that excited to bring
in my colleague, Dave Travis,
who leads up our content
work on the SAT side
Dave, good to see you.
- Good to see you Sal. How are you doing?
I live in (Indistinct) Massachusets
so I don't really have a, I
feel for you Californians,
for sure.
- Yeah, at least the air quality
isn't horrible so it's
like, you can go for a walk,
but it is kind of scary to look.
Apparently there was an
earthquake in New Jersey
so all sorts of stuff is
going on in the world now,
above and beyond many of the things
that we've been talking about for weeks
but it may be a good place to start,
I think some people know
that we have SAT work on Khan Academy
some people might not be
familiar, just give us,
what do we have for student's out there?
and then what's maybe the latest
that you've been working on?.
- Sure, so Official SAT Practice
is a product
that you can find @www.Khanacademy.org/sat
You can link your PSAT
scores if you have them
and the system will give you
personalized recommendations
about why you should practice.
We have thousands of SAT questions
that we developed in collaboration
with the college board
and so very well aligned
core practice questions.
We also have eight full
length practice tests
that you can take online
and we have a pile of great tips
and strategies, articles and videos.
Every one of those questions
has a work solution,
so just totally loaded
with great resources.
When I first started working
for Khan Academy in 2016,
when the SAT sort of changes format,
that first thing I wanted to do
'cause I'd run my own
private test prep company
in Manhattan for a while
was to bring all those tips
and strategies to Khan Academy
and build out that Tips
and Strategies tab,
so we're actually working
on some new stuff this year.
One of the things that we have learned
is that those students do better
these are best practices
that we've learned in the last four years.
If you take the recommendations
that the system says, "Hey,
you should practice this",
students who take those recommendations
do better on test day
than those who don't.
We've also seen that students
who take full-length practice tests one
or two at least generally do better
than those students who don't
take for like practice tests
and we know that students who spend time
going over the questions they missed
and looking at the solution steps
and taking advantage
of the resources we have,
the articles and videos
and explanations for
why an answer is wrong
and why the right answer is right,
also do better on test
day than those who don't.
So with the new content
we're gonna sort of pull up a list
of what some of that
stuff is that our team
and I have been working on,
we have new reading videos,
a new set of reading videos
that go question by question through
and talk about not just
how to do that question,
but techniques that you can use
when you see a question like
that on test you solve it
and that's so,
it's a citing textual evidence question,
you can approach it in a specific way.
So we're about to see like
where you're gonna find
the Tips and Strategies tab,
which is next to the Practice tab
and the Full Test ab
and the Tips and Strategies
tab is just loaded
with good resources.
So if you're spending a lot
of time in your Practice tab
and you haven't spent
much time in the Tips
and Strategies tab,
I'd encourage you to find out more about
how to approach a literature
passage and its questions.
So this is one new resource
that we have in the last few months,
we also have a new short articles
about every single question
type in the reading test
and in the writing and language test
and finally we have new math articles,
they're not done all of them yet,
but you'll see there are four of them
about in the middle of last week
and now there are more and we're aiming
to get all 41 math skills
have a full explanation
of what exactly from
each one of these skills,
solving the systems
of linear equations,
operations polynomials
What exactly do you need
to know for the SAT?,
and these articles include videos from Sal
that are from the main content,
the main library at Khan Academy
and also ways to practice
and we were hoping
that teachers may also
use this to understand
what exactly their students need to know,
on test day for each of the
skills on the SAT in math.
So we'd love to hear from you,
how you think these are these work
and just stay tuned
'cause we're in the process
of making more of them
with our team, our small but mighty team.
- Yeah, and let's look on this slide here,
we can see when some of the information
for so folks can stay up
to date on what's going on,
'cause obviously with
all the coronavirus stuff
in the world, some things
are a little bit fluid,
so it's good to be able to get updates
from the college board as you mentioned,
we've all been working very closely with
and these are the upcoming
weekend test dates.
There's already some questions
coming in from Facebook,
Javi Suresh is asking,
"How to practice for SAT math?",
maybe I'll add a little bit to it
SAT math or verbal, let's
say you are a student
who was taking the SAT a math from now,
what would you, 16 year
old, Dave Travis be doing?
What would your next month
of your life look like?
- If I were 16 years old,
I'd be freaking out I'm so
(Dave laughing)
- You are not 16 years old?
- No, (Indistinct)
(Dave laughing)
I would definitely for
students who are a month out,
it depends on how many
practice tests you've taken.
It depends on, on what the gap
is, you're trying to close,
but for sure I would visit
our help desk article
which spells out a set
of our recommendations.
We kind of spend time a few months ago
during school closures, what we recommend.
I recently updated it
a couple of weeks ago
to say for those of you who
are about to take the test,
what should you do?.
With four weeks I'd practice.
If you have let's say you
have 45 minutes a day,
you're gonna put into it.
If you had that time,
I'd spend three or four
days taking those 45 minutes
to take practice recommendations.
I'd take a practice to
past every other week maybe
but one thing I'd avoid
is just doing question after question
we found that students who
just do question after question
and don't take that
time to review articles,
about how to do questions like that
or review the solution
steps for each question,
like definitely use the Review tab
or the Review function in
our Oficiall SAT Practice,
which enables you to go
over every single question
that you have ever attempted in the system
and just review what went wrong on that?
How do we recommend you might
do the problem differently
and then try the question again.
Maybe you cover up the answers
and see whether you can
get it right this time.
Yeah, that's all (indistinct),
- My gut sense on that if
I were sixteen-year-old Sal
and we're more responsible
version of that,
probably 45 Minutes even an
hour, a day, as you mentioned,
like really index on the practice,
get the feedback and then review,
don't just keep going through questions,
like re reflect on why you
might've gotten a question wrong
or whether there's a faster
or a better way of doing it
and then trying to redo it.
But I would probably spend my Monday
through Friday 45
minutes hour a day, doing
that recommended practice,
trying to get skills leveled up
and then try to take at minimum
of well, maybe a full-length practice test
or maybe break it up
into two days Saturday
and Sunday.
But as I get close to the
test use maybe my Saturdays
to try and take as close to full-length,
this practice as possible
so that I can kind of build up
that stamina so that I'm not surprised
that I have to sit two or
three hours on the test day,
but yeah, that makes a lot of sense to me.
There's a question here
from YouTube, Suzanna Garcia,
Domingez, probably our MVPQ
most valuable question,
asker and MVQA. She
asks, "Hi Sal and Dave,
how can doing the essay section
help, is the essay really
necessary"?.
So what's your view on the
essay section generally
and how would you recommend a prep for it
either on Khan Academy
or off of Khan Academy?
- Great question.
The essay is optional,
but as many things are in life,
those things that are maybe recommended
are things that are that
many colleges like to see
and I have heard that if
colleges really want to get
an authentic piece of a
writing sample from somebody,
they are able to actually
see your essay from the SAT
because colleges know that if you write,
if you submit an essay as part
of your college application,
you may have had help.
So if they're wondering that
something doesn't add up,
they might actually look
at your copy of your essay.
So if you feel like it
could be a strong component
of your overall profile,
I'd say, definitely take it
and I know that many colleges
do encourage people to take it,
as for preparation it
is definitely important
to understand that the SAT essay topic
is a lot like a writing assignment
you might get in college.
So preparing for the SAT
is a process of preparing
to become a more effective
writer in college.
We have a lot of great content in the tips
and strategy section on our system.
But I would say that you wanna figure out
like one sort of top tip
is like learn about logos,
which is appeals to reason,
learn about Pathos,
which is appeals to emotion.
The assignment is, some
of you don't know us
lets ake a step back.
The assignment is to
explain you read a passage
and then you need to
explain how the author
is using elements of
using writerly techniques
to persuade their
audience of their position
and there are very clear ingredients
that go into persuasive writing
and we identify them in our tips
and strategies articles about
the essay so check those out.
- Yeah, know I really like that,
'cause you're absolutely right,
I talked to a college admissions,
I talked to one recently
about a completely different project,
but on the application
that I was a little bit
skeptical of to what degree
is your own work.
But obviously if they see an essay done
in kind of practical format,
they know that's your work
so that super valuable and
there's really great ways,
great advice for practice.
So there's a comment here,
I'll just read it out
and then there's a lot
of really good questions
from Robin Schwartz Facebook,
"teachers learn a ton
about the SAT by taking it every now
and then highly recommend it
studying for the SAT makes you smarter,
like preparing for a
marathon makes you fitter",
so that's just a fun
comment from a teacher
and absolutely right, it's been a while,
since many of us took the
SAT and the SAT has evolved
and so as educators, yeah,
it sounds like Robin's got the right idea.
It's good to have a student empathy
and you actually might learn
things and realize you're having fun.
So there's a couple of questions here
about number of SATs to take in timing
so Nicola Frost from Facebook says,
"How many times should
a student take the SAT?"
And then Jesus Through Mary
from YouTube interesting name,
says, "Do you think it
benefits ninth graders
to take the SAT prep
even if they haven't completed
all the relevant coursework?"
My thought is that they will at least know
what they are in for down the road.
So what are your thoughts on that?
How many times did you take it?
when is it reasonable
to start using SAT prep?
I have some views, but I'd love yours.
- Yeah, I mean,
all the rule book is being
rewritten at the moment
the college board has
encouraged knows that
the students may not be
able to take the SAT.
The students now they don't need
many colleges have gone
SAT optional this year,
the college board is
encouraging admissions offices
to understand that due to COVID,
there are limited opportunities students
to take these tests
and so as a result,
most colleges aren't requiring
a test score for the
upcoming admissions cycle.
So many are extending their deadlines
or accepting scores after deadlines pass.
So the rule book is
kind of being rewritten,
but a year ago,
I would've said you
shouldn't really take it more
than three times as sort of a hard like
that's you shouldn't do any more than that
and you should also
shouldn't take it officially
until you have taken a practice test
that leads you to believe
that you're gonna get a score
that you're gonna be happy with.
Yeah,
- I mean, I know that's consistent
my advice what I would say
is there's opportunities
to sometimes take it in middle school.
That can be a fun experience
'cause even though you might
not have seen all of the mathematics yet
or some of you might have
or you might not be fully
at the reading comprehension level
that you're gonna be in a couple of years,
it's a great practice run
and that usually is one
that kind of doesn't count
towards the total number you're taking
'cause you took it to the middle school
and if you're interested in that,
it gives you exposure to the test
and it goes to Jesus
Through Mary's question,
it let's you know what's coming
and there's some programs
and summer camps that you can get into.
But I agree with Dave,
I think three is on the high side,
I would recommend your
ticket once in middle school,
if you're kind of precocious
and you're curious,
I think there's another question
that Nicola Frost asks
about what classes to take
in order to be prepared.
A lot of people think the SAT
has like all this really
esoteric advanced stuff in it.
The math is only like
the core of algebra two,
not even like the edge
case algebra two stuff,
it's like quadratics, basic functions,
but making sure you really
understand that well.
So I would say once you
understand your algebra two
reasonably well
and actually just
straight algebra one will
probably get you most of it,
get you through algebra one and geometry,
will get you through probably 80%
or 90% of the math on the SAT
and then a little bit of algebra two.
You're good and there aren't
these tricky questions
that they used to have from decades ago.
They're all very much
aligned with standards,
not something that you
would not necessarily see
in a traditional classroom,
but it's good to get that practice.
So I would recommend maybe
taking it once your sophomore year,
once you've gotten through
algebra, geometry maybe
and maybe the end of your sophomore year
and maybe once your junior year,
if you're kind of on a
little bit of a faster track
or maybe taking it once at the
beginning of your junior year
and then maybe at either at the
very end of your junior year
is probably, that might make sense too.
But I think two is kind of a sweet spot
and then have space for third,
if you really need to would be my advice.
- The most frequent pattern
that many students do
is they take it in March or May
and then again, they fall
of their senior year.
So, sorry junior year,
March or may by that Point,
you'd probably have learned the math
you need to do well on the SAT
and then you might take a subject test
or might have APS that
you're doing in May or June
and then if you want
to take the SAT again,
take it in August or September,
October before you apply to college.
- Yeah, and I'll add
the reason why I tell people
beginning two in junior years
that hopefully by the end of junior year
you're happy with your
score and you're done
and you can relax a little
bit more in the fall,
but then you have also a backup.
If you have to take it again,
another I guess corollary to that question
is when is it too early
to use the SAT practice?
I've actually been recommending
a lot of folks to use the resources
that Dave and team have been creating.
As soon as you've
essentially taken algebra one
or even a little bit of
geometry, it's a great resource
and also the reading comprehension work,
I'd say, if you're at kind of an eighth
or ninth grade reading level,
you can engage and actually
right now during COVID,
it is a great resource to make sure
that your reading comprehension
and some of your grammar
skills don't atrophy
right now.
So I highly recommend it,
I actually think it's
not just going to prepare
for the SAT two days earlier comment,
it makes you college ready
and you will just happen
to do well on the SAT
and other things because of that.
The other questions,
See, let me find there is
a question from Facebook,
which is a couple of interesting
questions from Facebook,
Theresa Vasileva is saying, "My
SAT was canceled for August,
how can I keep up with
my new one in December?"
So I guess there could be a couple
of interpretations of that.
Maybe Theresa is asking what she should do
for the December test
or maybe making sure it
doesn't get canceled,
answer that any way you see fit Dave.
- Okay, cool,
Well, if you're lining up to
take the test in December,
it's about, you have
September, October, November
about 12 weeks out.
I do recommend that you check
out our help desk article,
hopefully we'll be able to
post a link in the chat,
that'll tell you what the 12 week program
is what I think is the
best I could come up with
as a strategy, a 12 week
strategy for somebody
to prepare for the SAT.
I'm sorry about August, Yeah,
we don't know what's gonna happen,
in September, October, November,
it could be that your
test site is canceled
or it needs to close for whatever reason
and that's one of the
reasons acknowledging
that the college board is
encouraging colleges to take,
take scores later than
they might otherwise do
and it's the reason why many colleges
are going SAT optional this year.
So if you're trying to
prepare for December
please do check out that help desk article
because it's jam packed
a picture's worth a thousand words,
like you've, it's pretty thorough
so do all that stuff.
- Yeah, there is question
another question from
Suzanna Domingez from YouTube,
"How close are the Khan
Academy practice test
to the real SAT test?"
- Great question,
they are real SAT tests.
So that's about as close as you can get.
(Dave laughing)
- So they are the exact same tests
you will find in the
official ICT Study Guide,
which is the big blue book
that the College Board Publishes,
of those eight tests,
six of them are actually administered
and two of them were ones before
that were from 2016,
but they're all as close
as you can possibly get.
We have the best online practice materials
and the real practice tests
that nobody else has access to that.
So if you're looking for
real practice questions,
which is definitely a best practice
when you move into other
test prep programs,
every unit has a really,
does their best to try to get questions
that are just like the real thing.
But our practices are the real thing
and our practice questions were developed
with college board the test maker.
So we're as close as you can get really,
and that is free.
- Yeah, that's free,
it doesn't get better than that
the best things in life aren't free.
So another quick, maybe we have time
for one more question from YouTube,
Don Woodfield is asking,
"Does taking multiple SAT practices
improve your score on the actual SAT
or will it do the opposite?
I did it myself during the summer,
taking it multiple times
and practicing every day.
and I improved".
What's your view?
(Sal laughing)
My view Don is if you are
taking more pull SATs,
just taking them one after another
isn't necessarily improve your score,
but if you take it, you reflect on it,
you see what you missed,
didn't miss you practice,
you do some substantive practice.
Then the next time that you take it,
hopefully several months after that
or a year after that,
you are likely to improve
and there are schools once again,
if you don't take a ton of SATs,
if you take like five SATs
they're gonna think that's weird.
But if you took two SATs or three SATs,
many schools will actually take
your best score in each section,
so that also is to your advantage
and anything to add to that, Dave.
- Yeah, I'd say that practice tests,
we have the eight real practice tests.
Don't like, I wouldn't
just use all those up
if you're a intense practicer
and you just want to take practice tests
after practice tests
hold the real ones in reserve
until like you're a
month away from the test,
if you're like three months out,
you should take one practice
test every two or three weeks
with practice in between and reflection
on how to approach questions differently,
learning how learning the strategies
and techniques from the Tips
and Strategies articles.
But yeah, I think we've said it
before earlier in this cast,
it's super important not to
just keep on doing questions
and you need to reflect and review
how are you gonna approach the questions
you got wrong differently next time
when you see them in the wild on test day?
- Yeah, this is super helpful, Dave.
I unfortunately, I'm gonna have to cut
I have a hard stop in a
few minutes, but Dave,
any parting words of,
of good luck or wisdom
for all of the aspiring SAT test takers.
- Sure, yeah,
let me see the more you
do it, the better you get
as is true with so many things in life.
Yeah the SAT is just one part
of your college application,
remember the extracurriculars
and your grades in any volunteer
or work experience your
essays, your interview,
all those are ingredients
in your college application
that are just as important, if not more so
than the SAT.
So just keep it all in perspective,
but if you have the time
and have the hunger to improve your score,
Khan Academy is a great place to do it.
So good luck out there
and I believe in you
all, it's just so great
to have this opportunity to help people
do better on the SAT,
I really I'm grateful.
- Awesome. Thanks,
and I'll just add something
that Dave said earlier,
which is not only will it make you better
at SAT the way that the practice in front
of the SAT is designed,
is these are skills
you're gonna need in college.
So regardless of what happens on the SAT,
this will just make you
more likely to succeed
and frankly in high school and In college.
So completely agree with
that, I also agree with Dave,
like the more that you make
something big in your mind,
the more that'll stress you out
and it actually might
undermine your performance.
So I highly recommend mindfulness,
doing what you need to
do, focus on the process
and then the results
will be what they are.
Don't define yourself by that,
it is part of your college application
it does not define who
you are as a human being
obviously this is all under
the Khan Academy umbrella,
but I can toot our
collective horn because Dave
and the team and many others
have done the bulk of the work here,
that it really is an incredible resource.
I highly recommended it
we have efficacy studies
that improves student's outcomes.
There's things that cost
thousands of dollars
that have no efficacy studies behind the
and this is free and it's
done with the college board.
I'll also throw out a
completely separate project
from Khan Academy,
but one that I've been
helping out with advising
called schoolhouse.world,
which is also not going to
be doing live SAT tutoring
from volunteers, for
anyone who might need it.
So what I would recommend is
do everything Dave mentioned,
put that 45 minutes hour a day,
do the recommended practice,
try to level up skills on the weekends
don't use up all your practice tests,
but start spacing them out
as you get closer to the test
and then if you have
questions in specific domains,
you actually can get free
live group tutoring sessions
on @www.schoolhouse.world.
Once again, that's a separate project
than Khan Academy,
disclaimer necessarily it's a startup
it's not as polished,
as everything we have on Khan Academy,
but it's worth looking into,
so Dave, thanks so much for
answering these questions
and I will,
yeah and thanks everyone else for joining
always a fun conversation.
Please join us tomorrow
we're gonna have David Banks,
founder of the Eagle Academy,
which speaks "Empowering at risk young men
to learn, succeed, and develop character".
So we're really excited about having
that conversation,
tomorrow it's a really impressive school
or set of schools that David
has founded and now leads.
So I will see you tomorrow.